thank you for calling reason dot TV
please press 1 for English isn't she
beautiful for more than 100 years the
Statue of Liberty has been welcoming
immigrants to the United States you know
except for the Native Americans we're
all descendants of immigrants there's a
poem on the Statue of Liberty that says
give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to be free
I wonder what Lady Liberty would say
about your hunky superstar footballers
like David Beckham I think David Beckham
coming to America is great for the game
of soccer I think David Beckham coming
to the MLS is a great thing not only for
the galaxy not only for the MLS but for
soccer football in general for America
Oh
Americans especially LA Galaxy fans were
very excited and greeted David Beckham
with open arms when he came here to play
in Los Angeles even though he took the
roster spot away from some poor
hard-working American kid so I guess
we're really welcoming when it comes to
rich famous Brits and we love our
Beatles but are we as welcoming when it
comes to people from other countries
tonight California faces a population
crisis the state's population growth is
going to double over the next 40 years
massive illegal immigration the primary
reason it is not racist it is not
nativist it is not xenophobic to worry
about assimilation this is not about
race this is about national security
this is about economics this is about
social but it is about race because
there's so many Latinos involved in the
legalization process it isn't the fear
of Russians coming to the u.s. it's the
fear of 40 million Latinos coming to
change the whole fabric of the country
that is the fear we are testing our
willingness to actually hold on to
something called the English language
something that is the glue that is
supposed to hold us together as a nation
we are becoming a bilingual nation and
that is not good but this attitude
really isn't anything new
every wave of immigrants to the United
States whether they were Jewish Irish
Italian or Chinese was met with disdain
by the descendants of immigrants who
arrived earlier many Americans worried
that immigrants will refuse to learn
English and take over our country with
their foreign culture I don't want to
sound too confident but I felt that I
was going to score soon as I had to boy
my my hands now Beckham talks a little
funny but at least he speaks English so
fitting in here won't be a big problem
for him but what about immigrants from
other countries a mother and father
originally born here but both my grandma
on both side my grandparents actually
came over right through Ellis Island
so third generation
do you speak Italian I do parla tell you
yeah below spend yo tambien yes so when
you talk about yourself do you call
yourself an American absolutely
absolutely not at all I'm pretty proud
of you everyone every tattoo I own is
Italian so I would say I'm very proud of
the time but I still just go straight
American with it family came from
Belgium so they had that
you know soccer background so kind of
the same thing they kind of brought
soccer over and first generation you
know born here my parents speak Flemish
and I can understand it a little bit but
you know they speak it and they do great
I understand what they say as far as
speaking it's a little bit tougher he
doesn't he's American all the way the
truth is that immigrants to the United
States do assimilate pretty quickly true
many first-generation immigrants may not
speak English very well
but a hundred percent of their
grandchildren will speak American like
you and me I don't know about you but I
think we should welcome all peaceful
people to our country they get to pursue
the American dream and we get to benefit
from all the wonderful things that
immigrants bring to our country like
good old-fashioned sucker sounds like a
pretty good deal to me
you